[Music]
today we are adopting the eu disability
rights strategy
for 2021-2013
this strategy lays out our plan to
implement the un convention on the
rights of persons with disabilities
until 2030.
the new eu disability rights strategy
provides
a strong framework to ensure that
persons with disabilities
can participate equally in all areas of
life
our ambitions are high and change will
require
everyone's commitment we want to
guarantee that all persons with
disabilities in the eu
enjoy their human rights on an equal
basis with others
have equal access to participate in our
society
and economy are able to decide where
how and with whom they want to live can
move freely in the eu
regardless of their support needs and no
longer experience discrimination
of course we cannot do this alone we
will work
closely with national authorities
persons with disabilities will be part
of the dialogue
and the process we are stronger when all
our citizens
are valued and included i am committed
to delivering
a union of equality
you